We started off and we create a static map of only the countries and
drawn them without any of the data from our World Cup attendances.
The next improvement we've made is that we added bubbles or circles
corresponding to the home country and the total attendance for that year.
Making what's often called a thematic map by combining our static geographic map
with some data.
The theme in our case being the World Cup.
The next step of this improvement was to create the stem of our
martini glass and an author driven narrative.
Where we leveraged animation to cycle through all the years of the World Cup,
displaying both the participating countries and
teams and where the world cup was hosted and what its attendance was.
And remember, through both the animation, and
the negative space created by only showing the participating teams.
We could see that in the early tournaments of the World Cup, the participating
teams and countries, were often localized to where the tournament was held.
Now, I'm sure there's plenty of causes for
this, and I don't want to fall victim to confusing correlation with a cause,
but intuitive exclamation that world travel wasn't what it is today.
In crossing the Atlantic and the Pacific, especially before airplanes became
commonplace, could be considered quite difficult.
The second takeaway from our author-driven narrative is that in addition to
conveying all the attendances of the World Cup have changed over the years,
is that we could see in the early days,
the World Cup was mainly hosted either in South America or Europe.
And perhaps this is one of the reasons why South America and European teams,
often dominate the World Cup, both historically and in modern tournaments.
And the fourth iteration of our map
was to enable a reader driven narrative through interaction.
We did so by adding buttons which correspond to every year of the World Cup so
that a reader, who might be interested in one years as compared to another,
could very easily see how the participants and the attendances and
the host country or rather what data we have represented on
our map has changed from one year to the next.
This also enabled us to compare disjoint years, which may not be sequential, for
example, comparing 1938s games with 1982s games through
animation alone we would have to wait for the entire sequence to go through.
And we may not be able to remember what it looked like in 1938 compared to
the year of interest, unless we've seen the animation go through many,
many times.
So while in the author-driven narrative,
we've communicated our interesting insights from the World Cup Games, be it
that early tournaments were often localized in the participating countries.
And the tournament mainly started off both being hosted in South America and
Europe, but also having many of the participating countries from South America
or Europe which might be a reason for their dominance in the games today.
They've simply been doing it for longer.
The reader-driven narrative allows the user to approach our visualization and
discover their own story.
And by combining both the author-driven portion and the reader-driven, we've
created a very powerful and dynamic story around the history of the World Cup.
And returning to our martini glass, remember that the static map and
the bubble map or thematic map create a very solid foundation for
our interactive narrative to come.
Our author-driven narrative, enabled by animation,
took our reader along a narrow stem of the glass, conveying the interesting
stories that we found in the data, before the interaction of our graphic.
Enable them to explore and
discover their own insights in our data through a reader driven narrative.
And through all of these components, we've created an engaging and
effective visualization.